mark davis the raiders owner recently
suggested and these were
comments that were made to the las vegas
review journal as part of an article
that primarily was focused on mark
davis's intense objection to putting
tarp over the first eight rows of the
seats in his new state you know he's got
this new toy and he can't fully play
with it right it's like you got this new
toy that you've wanted forever
and one of the pieces is broken and you
got to send away to the company that
made it to send that piece so until then
you've got a toy that is missing one of
its pieces and it pisses you off i can't
remember what toy it was for me but
haven't we all been there this toy that
we really want we get it and something's
broken and we try to make do with what
we have that's mark davis with his new
stadium something's broken he can't have
seats in the first eight rows and he's
mad about it well in that same article
he pointed out that
they may have to do a bubble concept by
the time it's all said and done it's one
thing to protect players from fans but
how do you protect players from players
and maybe their best bet is to do a
bubble approach look i don't think a
bubble approach is gonna work and it's
definitely not gonna work
if you are coming up with a bubble
approach on the fly like it can't be
plan b bubbles gotta be plan a if you're
gonna pull bubble off bubble is playing
a and bubble was put in place three
months ago when they didn't begin to
make the plans for a bubble
that put them on the path toward
a non-bubble environment and i wrote
about it march 29 people thought i was
crazy you take everybody to a remote
location
you build enough fields to play six
seven games simultaneously you have a
whole complex there you build
dormitories look it's not going to be
cheap it's not going to be easy and it's
not something you can throw together on
a moment's notice but that's the best
bubble
for the nfl because there's too many
people there's too many people who would
break the bubble you need a true bubble
to make it work for the nfl if they
would take all the teams in las vegas
maybe that's why mark davis is
suggesting the possibility of a bubble
approach maybe he wants to host the nfl
in vegas this year how do you keep
everyone in the bubble
think about it 65 players per team
coaches
support staff family members presumably
presumably they'll have family members
there you're gonna you're gonna pull
these guys away from their families for
four months
and and and dare suggest the possibility
of a pay cut when you're doing that to
them there's gonna be guys who bust out
of that bubble nightclub 10 minutes away
whatever the case may be and then if
they get the virus there and they bring
it back to the bubble you got a problem
so i just don't think the bubble is
practical and i think if the nfl finds
itself
thinking about a bubble on the fly
if you're in that position where you're
having those thoughts you need to do
that the better approach may be just to
pull the plug and be done with it and i
hope it doesn't come to that i have been
rooting for months for football to
happen there's a group out there that
seems to think not like an organized
group as far as i know but there's
there's a collection of individuals of
like mine they think that anyone who
points out the things that the nfl
should be worried about in order to pull
off the season those people are rooting
against the season well no i
we're rooting against the nfl being as
oblivious as way too many people walking
around without masks are because if
football season doesn't happen one of
the big reasons is going to be too many
people were either too selfish or too
dumb to comply with the guidelines and
do the things aimed at slowing or
eliminating the spread of the virus
period
period
so get mad at those of us who have been
saying what about this what about this
you need to think about this you need to
think about
that and go ahead and be
be blissful in your ignorance because
those of you who decided that this was
simply the flu those of you who decided
to listen to the charlatans out there
who are trying to make a buck by telling
you what you want to hear you know
sometimes
we must eat vegetables we can't have
candy
sometimes we need to pass on the candy
well you've got these folks out there
just force feeding candy to the people
who want to feel like they're okay that
they're not jerks
for failing to do the things that
they're supposed to do
and that's part of the problem it's part
of the problem and the folks in the
media who have been pushing that bs
place in hell as far as i'm concerned i
hope i'm not there to witness it i
i hope i'm not there to say man he's
really got it rough oh wait uh anyway um
that's all i got to say about the bubble
approach it's it's i'm concerned
but i'm still consciously optimistic
and uh
i hope they get it figured out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports